[Musik]
Deutschland im Juli
2021 es ist das Bewusstsein da dass
sowas vielleicht auch wieder passieren
wird es war nichts mehr da es war eine
ganze Ernte die wegggeschwommen
ist die Flutkatastrophe im Atal hat
gezeigt wie gefährlich stark Regen ist
und wie unvorbereitet wir
sind
überschömmung wie im artal werden eben
als einzigartige Katastrophe
[Musik]
abgetan im Prinzip kann man aber das was
hier im Aral passiert auf alle
mittelgewiürksregionen
übertragen was hat der Klimawandel damit
zu tun und wie bereiten wir uns auf
extreme Niederschläge
vor
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ein sonniger Septembermorgen in Dernau
mehr als zwei Jahre nach der
Flutkatastrophe kann in den Weinbergen
des ateils wieder ganz normal die
Weinlese
stattfinden
[Musik]
für die Winzerinnen Maike und DTE Näkel
ist das immer etwas
Besonderes wir haben das große Glück
dass wir vom Pflanzen der Rebe
bis zu dem Tag wo der Kunde den Wein im
Glas hat sind wir immer dabei und können
dann die Freude sehen äh die derjenige
bei beim Probieren und beim Trinken
[Musik]
hat das Wetter spielt eine große Rolle
für die Erntezeit die Trauben müssen
genau zum richtigen Zeitpunkt geerntet
werden den herauszufinden ist
mittlerweile eine große
Herausforderung wir merken seit 15
Jahren dass sich sukzessive das Klima
verändert wir merken es ganz extrem im
Weinbau vor sagen wir mal 10 Jahren war
die Lese mindestens vier bis se Wochen
später wenn man noch mal so in die
Vergangenheit schaut war das Wetter und
das Klima so üers Jahr ausgeglichener
der Regen kam ausgeglichener es gab
nicht so extreme Hitzeperioden das ist
heute anders wochenlang kein Regen oder
wochenlang so gezielte starke Regen
aufkommen wo wir plötzlich viele Liter
hintereinander bekommen das war früher
alles tatsächlich gemäßigter und ist
heute alles stärker und
extremer
die a ist das größte zusammenhängende
Rotweinanbaugebiet
Deutschlands viele leben hier seit
Generationen vom Weinbau dafür ist das
atteil mit seinen steilen
Weinbergterrassen und dem fast
mediterranen Mikroklima der perfekte
[Musik]
Ort doch seit der Flutkatastrophe ist im
Atal nichts mehr wie es einmal
[Musik]
war
juli
2021 es regnet
tagelang in der Nacht vom 14 auf den 15
juli erreicht der Starkregen schließlich
seinen katastrophalen
Höhepunkt der Regen der letzten Tage
verwandelt die a in eine zerstörerische
Flutwelle die alles mit sich
reißt
[Musik]
das extreme Wetterereignis fordert mehr
als 180 Menschen leben mit über 40
Milliarden Euro an Schäden ist es zudem
die bisher teuerste Naturkatastrophe der
deutschen
Geschichte ist das schon eine Folge des
Klimawandels
mit dieser Frage beschäftigt sich die
Physikerin Frederike Otto sie forscht am
Imperial College in London zu
extremwetterereignissen auch zur
[Musik]
alflut bei den Überschwemmung im artal
haben wir nicht die Überschwemmungen
selbst angeguckt in unserer Studie
sondern die stark Regenfälle die eben zu
diesem üerschämmung geführt haben und
dann wieder die Frage gestellt welche
Rolle spielt der Klimawandel in die
diesen stark Regenfällen und haben
rausgefunden dass aufgrund des Menschen
gemachten Klimawandels diese starke
Regenfälle ungefähr doppelt so
wahrscheinlich sind wie sie es ohne
Klimawandel gewesen
wä klimaforscherinnen sind sich sicher
dass Starkregen überall in Deutschland
immer häufiger auftritt mit teils
verheerenden
Folgen je höher die globale
Mitteltemperatur steigt der do stärker
m steigt auch die Gefahr für extrem
intensive Niederschläge bei ein Grad
globale Wärmung erhöht sich die
Luftfeuchtigkeit um etwa 7% was ungefähr
im globalen Mittel dann eben auch zu 7%
intensiveren Niederschlägen führt 7%
hört sich nicht viel an das kann aber
den den Unterschied zwischen bisschen
nassen Straßen und vielen vielen Toten
ausmachen
warme Luft speichert mehr Wasserdampf
als kalte dementsprechend kann mehr
Wasser abregnen je wärmer also der
Sommer in Deutschland ist desto heftiger
werden die
Regenfälle durch den Klimawandel regnet
es aber auch immer öfter das zeigt die
Forschung von Tanja Winterrad die
Physikerin arbeitet beim Deutschen
Wetterdienst
[Musik]
Niederschläge in täglicher Auflösung
werden seit den 1950er Jahren gemessen
wir sehen an diesen Messreihen dass wir
einen Anstieg der extremen
Niederschlagsereignisse haben sowohl in
Deutschland als auch in Europa und auch
weltweit gibt es Hinweise auf diese
Zunahme im September 2023 hat das
Sturmtief Daniel zu schweren
Überflutungen geführt in Libyen gab es
nach dem Bruch zweier Staudämme über
11000 tote auch in Griechenland der
Türkei und Bulgarien sorgte der
Starkregen für verheerende
Überschwemmungen solche extremen
Regenfälle können grundsätzlich überall
auftreten weiß Hanja
winterrat wir sehen Häufung in
mittelbirgsregion und auch im
Voralpenland aber letztendlich kann
stark Regen jeden
treffen
in einigen Regionen Deutschlands ist es
aber wahrscheinlicher dass das Zuhause
von Menschen durch den Starkregen
beschädigt
wird im Norden Deutschlands sind nur
wenige Gebäude durch die Folgen von
Starkregen bedroht in den Mittelgebirgen
und im Alpenvorland ist der Anteil der
gefährdeten Häuser dagegen deutlich
höher in Thüringen beispielsweise sind
fast ein Viertel der Wohngebäude durch
Starkregen
bedroht
[Musik]
besonders hohe Gefahr besteht für
Siedlungen die in einem Tal oder in der
Nähe eines Bachs
liegen in ganz Deutschland trifft das
auf rund 12% der Häuser
zu Meike und dirte nkel haben am eigenen
Leib erfahren wie gefährlich das Leben
in Flussnähe werden
kann ich
auch das war schon krass und auch wie
das gerochen hat nach Schlamm und Wein
gleichzeitig und ich fand diese Gewalt
einfach dass das da dass ist alles außen
aufgerissen war jeder der denke ich anem
Gewässer an dem Fluss lebt der der kennt
Hochwasser auch wir haben uns ja an dem
Tag auf Hochwasser vorbereitet so wie
wir das eben kennen Sandsäcke gepackt
Sachen hochgestellt dass es dann in der
Höhe und in dem Ausmaß
passiert das das kann man sich
rückblickend noch gar nicht richtig
vorstellen dass es passiert
[Musik]
ist nicht überall hat Starkregen
allerdings so dramatische Folgen wie im
ahal meint die klimaforscherin Frederike
Otto in anderen Teilen Deutschlands gibt
es solche stark Regenfälle deutlich
häufiger und da wärden sie gar nicht so
ungewöhnlich nur sind die Konsequenzen
deutlich geringer
[Musik]
Ende Juni
2021 extremer Regen in der okermark ohne
größere Schäden oder gar Tote zwei
Wochen später regnet es im ahal ähnlich
viel doch der Schaden ist diesmal
enorm wir sind hier mit unserem
kälterhaus und
Produktionsgebäude nur 50 m von der A
weg haben uns aber immer so ein bisschen
in Sicherheit gewiegt als wir das vor 20
Jahren gebaut haben weil kein Mensch
sich dran erinnern konnte dass hier an
dieser Stelle jemals Wasser
[Musik]
war ein Großteil der Menschen in den
Katastrophengebieten rechnete nicht mit
starkem Hochwasser fast die Hälfte
wusste nicht was sie tun soll wie eine
Umfrage der Universität pozdam
zeigt
[Musik]
die Weingüter im ahartal wurden
besonders schwer getroffen keines von
ihnen hat die Flut unbeschadet
überstanden wir haben etwa 350
barikfässer gehabt sprich hier die
kleinen Eichenholzfässer und die sind
natürlich leider sehr sehr gut wommen
wir haben hier eine ganze Ernte so ein
ganzen Jahrgang
2020 ja
verloren an einigen Stellen war die
Flutwelle über 7 m hoch und zerstörte
alles was in ihrem Weg
lag sind hier im Prinzip jetzt an der
alten Außenmauer von unserem
ursprünglichen Gebäude wir mussten hier
auf dem Platz ein bisschen was anbauen
sprich mit einer zusätzlichen Halle mit
Containern weil unser zweiter
Gebäudekomplex mitten im Dorf komplett
zerstört wurde also so dass wir da
erstmal nicht mehr weiterarbeiten
konnten durch die Flut wurden alle
Betriebsgebäude der Winzerinnen zerstört
oder stark beschädigt so auch die alte
vinthek mittlerweile ist das nur noch
eine ja Ruine wir haben uns ja ziemlich
schnell nach der Flut dafür entschieden
dass wir das
aufgeben in der ehemaligen vinthek
sollen nun Wohnungen
entstehen natürlich denkt man immer noch
wie schade ne fünf Generationen vor
einem haben hier drin gelebt und
gearbeitet jetzt in der nächsten
Generation also wir sind die fünfte
Generation findet das nicht mehr
statt aufgeben kommt für die beiden
Schwestern nicht in Frage für sie ist
klar alles soll neu gemacht und besser
werden vor allem im Hinblick auf die
kommende Generation der Winzer Familie
Probierstube hier hinten
drin es scheint ja doch so zu sein dass
alle 100 Jahre so ein eine Katastrophe
passiert vielleicht auch schneller weil
ja sich Wetter und Klima ändern wir
wollen vermeiden dass die noch mal das
durchmachen müssen was wir hatten
diese einfach diese wahnsinnig
energiezehrende Zeit
die Angst um die eigene Existenz und das
wollen wir keinem von unseren Nachfahren
zumuten
isstraße hoch hier um die Kurve von
einem überstürzten Wiederaufbau halten
Meike und DTE nkel wenig stattdessen
bauen Sie den Betrieb an einer
hochwassersicheren Stelle neu
auf doch nicht überall im Tal wird so
vorausschauen neu aufgebaut der Biologe
Wolfgang Bü forscht seit über 40 Jahren
Imal und den Wiederaufbau mit
[Musik]
Unbehagen man hat hier vieles jetzt neu
gemacht schöner größer damit aber gegen
den Hochwasserschutz zum Teil
gearbeitet ein Beispiel dafür ist die
Burgwiese bei rech eigentlich eine
perfekte
wasserrückhaltefläche würde man sie
tiefer legen könnte sie große
Wassermengen aufnehmen und so die
Fluthöhe verringern doch stattdessen
türmen sich Berge an
Schutt wenn die nächste Flut kommt die
nimmt also diese Schuttberge die hier
aufgeschüttet sind wie nichts mit und
rech versinkt im
Schlamm besonders in Hochwasser
gefährdeten Regionen brauchen Gewässer
genug Platz um sich auszubereiten den
bekommen Sie immer seltener befürchtet
Wolfgang Büchs im artal hatte das
dramatische Folgen dabei sind Hochwasser
hier an sich nichts ungewöhnliches 1804
war der Niederschlag sogar höher als
2021 doch die Flutwelle war damals viel
niedriger der arthal Experte Wolfgang
büs kennt die Gründe
dafür ja das arthal hat einen
versiegelungsproblem wir haben nach
einem statistischen Jahrbuch 2021 eine
versiegelte Fläche von 11000 Hektar wenn
man das umrechnet und vergleicht mit dem
Bundesdurchschnitt ist die versiegelte
Fläche pro ein Wohner im Aal etwa 40%
höher als im üblichen Bundesdurchschnitt
wenn man das Gebiet nicht so bebaut
hätte und nicht so die Böden versiegelt
hätte dann dann wäre viel mehr Wasser
versickert und nicht in die Flüsse
gelaufen und hätte zu so ST steigenden
Pegelständen
geführt die Winzerinnen kamen mit dem
Leben davon doch all ihre Maschinen
wurden durch die Flutwelle zerstört oder
mitgerissen ausgerechnet zwei Monate vor
der
Traubenernte
es ist so dass der dass der Herbst also
die
Weinlese sowieso die arbeitsintensivste
Zeit des Jahres ist und in 2021 sind wir
im Prinzip schon sehr angeschlagen sehr
kaputt in die Ernte
gegangen für die Traubenernte mussten
sie in kürzester Zeit alle Geräte
ersetzen durch den Neubau in den
Weinbergen wollen Sie sich und Ihre
Ausrüstung in Zukunft vor Hochwasser
schützen
im ökologischen Weinbau wird der Boden
begrünt dadurch speichert er zum einen
mehr Wasser zum anderen wird so weniger
Erde abgetragen und ins Tal
runtergespült eine kleine aber effektive
Maßnahme doch sie allein kann das Tal
nicht vor den Wassermassen schützen
dafür braucht es verschiedene Maßnahmen
die das Wasser im Ernstfall
aufffangen das sind z.B Sportplätze die
als Rückhaltebecken auch dienen können
sie haben Parkplätze die sie dazu nutzen
können Dachbegrünung Fassadenbegrünung
Zisternen die also beim Straßenbau und
beim Bau in den Ortschaften angewendet
werden
können Wirtschaftswege so auch in den
Weinbergen müssten aus
wasserdurchlässigen Materialien
gefertigt werden und nicht aus Asphalt
damit das Wasser nicht wie auf einer
Leitbahn ins Tal hinunter
unterchießt würde man diese Maßnahmen
überall in Deutschland umsetzen ließen
sich die schlimmsten Folgen von
Starkregen
verhindern in dicht besiedelten Regionen
wie dem Atal könnten aber drastischere
Maßnahmen notwendig sein glaubt Wolfgang
Büchs insgesamt muss man aber versuchen
das Tal stärker zu entsiedeln und den
Leuten
alternativflächen wo Sie wohnen können
anzubieten für die Schwestern Meike und
DTE Näkel ist das keine
Option durch den Wein durch die rieben
die hier stehen und hier verwurzelt sind
wird das zu zu einer Heimat zu einer
Sache die man nicht einfach verlassen
kann genauso wie die Rebstöcke stehen
bleiben bleiben wir eben auch
hier Angst vor einer neuen Katastrophe
haben die Schwestern nicht seit wir
geboren sind kennen wir die a wir sind
an der A groß geworden und Angst ist da
keine es ist die bewusst das Bewusstsein
da dass
sowas passieren kann
ähm und vielleicht auch wieder passieren
wird m aber
nicht dass man in der ständigen Angst
davor lebt es ist immer noch
sehr kraftzerend was wir hier gerade zu
tun haben sehr energiezerend
sowohl für den Kopf als auch für den
Körper aber man hat so ein bisschen das
Gefühl dass
man jetzt eh schon das Schlimmste erlebt
hat und dass einen so schnell auch gar
nichts mehr stoppen kann die Schwestern
schauen nach vorne sie wollen auf das
nächste Hochwasser besser vorbereitet
sein die Auswirkungen des Klimawandels
spüren wir bereits jetzt auch in
Deutschland das wurde vielen erst nach
der verheerenden Flut im Sommer 2021
bewusst auch die Bundesregierung hat
erkannt dass sie mehr tun muss um
Deutschland auf die Auswirkungen des
Klimawandels vor zu bereiten wir haben
Studien die uns belegen dass wenn wir
keine Klimaanpassung oder Vorbereitung
auf die Klimaveränderungen betreiben wir
auf einen sehr sehr großen
Milliardenbetrag zulaufen über 200
Milliarden die dann auf uns
zukommen eine aktuelle Studie im Auftrag
des Wirtschaftsministeriums rechnet
sogar noch mit höheren Beträgen
ihrzufolge könnten auf Deutschland bis
2050 Kosten von 900 Milliarden Euro
zukommen die Studie zeigt jedoch auch
dass sich die Kosten des Klimawandels
senken lassen je mehr wir uns an den
Klimawandel anpassen und das Klima
schützen desto geringer sind die
Ausgaben in
Zukunft deshalb ist es gut und richtig
in Vorsorge in Anpassung zu investieren
und genau dafür haben wir jetzt etliche
Maßnahmen
angestoßen dastion Programm natürlicher
Klimaschutz soll mohre und Wälder
widerstandsfähiger
machen wenn diese Ökosysteme mehr Wasser
aufnehmen können schützt uns das auch
vor
Starkregen durch weitere Förderprogramme
können die Kommunen Fachleute
einstellen sie helfen dabei Gefahren
durch extremes Wetter frühzeitig zu
erkennen und die nötigen Vorkehrungen zu
treffen wir werden vermutlich nicht ganz
genau voraussagen können an dem und dem
Tag ist so und so viel Wasser in einer
bestimmten Stadt oder in einem
bestimmten Dorf zu erwarten aber sich
besser vorzubereiten und vor allem das
sehe ich als Bundesumweltministerin als
meine Hauptaufgabe an zu klären dass wir
die Natur brauchen damit Sie uns
unterstützen
kann Deutschland ist nicht gut auf
Extremwetterereignisse vorbereitet die
Frage ist ob die Maßnahmen der Bundes
Regierung diesen Zustand wirklich
[Musik]
verbessern ja im Grunde genommen müsste
man
Hochwasserschutzmaßnahmen und auch
insgesamt Klimaschutzmaßnahmen sehr
langfristig planen und auch Wege gehen
die für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
manchmal unbequem sind aber das
kontagariert mit den Wahlperioden die in
Deutschland vier oder 5 Jahre
betragen
doch nicht nur unser politisches System
erschwert die Umsetzung von
Schutzmaßnahmen wir fühlen uns in
Deutschland immer noch zu sicher
befürchtet klimaforscherin Frederike
Otto als ich in die Schule gegangen bin
in Deutschland habe ich in der Schule
wortwörtlich gesagt gekriegt in
Deutschland gibt's kein gefährliches
Wetter und das mag jetzt zwar ein
extremer Erdkundelehrer gewesen sein den
nicht hatte aber ich glaube diese
Grundhaltung ist nach wie vor sehr weit
verbreitet Meike und DTE nkel war schon
lange klar dass starker Regen ihnen
gefährlich werden
kann eine Katastrophe wie im Juli 2021
war für sie dennoch
unvorstellbar es war die Rede von
Hochwasser und wir wussten auch dass es
äh die Dimension eines jahrhundert
Hochwassers bekommt aber wir waren uns
gar nicht im Klaren was das genau
bedeutet und
ähm die Warnungen waren wahrscheinlich
nicht klar genug formuliert
ähm und deshalb haben wir uns eigentlich
bis kurz vor knapp sehr sicher gefühlt
bis es dann so schnell ging dass die
Ereignisse sich überschlagen haben und
man gar keine Chance mehr hatte zu
reagieren deswegen müssen wir uns schon
vor dem Ernstfall mit den nötigen
Schutzmaßnahmen beschäftigen wenn ein
solches Schadenereignis wie hier im
artal erstmal eingetreten ist dann steht
man unter dem Druck dass die Leute
natürlich ihr normales Leben wieder
haben wollen schnell wieder aufbauen
wollen das ist
eine vernünftige Planung die
entsprechend Zeit da braucht eigentlich
nicht mehr
[Musik]
möglich Meike nkel sieht das
ähnlich
wir finden es super wichtig dass sich
viele Menschen genau Gedanken machen wie
sie wieder aufbauen oder was Sie anders
machen das ist irgendwie schlauer und
besser ist als
vorher viele Hausbesitzer können das
aber nicht sie müssen wieder da aufbauen
wo ihr Haus vorher stand denn die
rheinland-felzische Landesregierung hat
genau festgelegt wo in Zukunft Häuser
stehen dürfen und wo nicht demnach
müssen von 9000 zerstörten Gebäuden nur
34 an einer neuen Stelle wieder
aufgebaut werden das könnte dem Atal zum
Verhängnis
[Musik]
werden Wolfgang böch rechnet damit dass
sich das Ereignis von 2021 wiederholen
wird das ist eine neue Flut geben wird
ist sehr wahrscheinlich natürlich ist
unsicher W dies eintritt wir haben
dieses Jahr Glück gehabt dass das Tief
Daniel nicht einige 100undert Kilometer
weiter westlich niedergegangen ist es
hätte leicht verschoben sein können und
dann das atil wieder treffen können
insofern kann sowas jedes Jahr wieder
passieren um dem vorzubeugen plant die
Bundesregierung Klimaschutz gesetzlich
zu
regeln deshalb wollen wir mit dem
klimaanpassungsgesetz einen
verbindlichen Rahmen dafür schaffen raus
aus der Freiwilligkeit damit auch in der
ganz normalen Bauleitplanung der
Stadtplanung Klima Anpassung in Zukunft
mitgedacht und mitgebaut wird für
Umweltministerin Steffi Lemke liegt die
Verantwortung aber nicht nur auf
Bundesebene das sind auch Länder das
sind Landkreise das sind Städte das sind
Dörfer und wir tun als Menschen gut
daran wenn wir uns gemeinsam auf
Klimaveränderung vorbereiten und der
beste die beste Vorbereitung auf die
Klimaveränderung ist jetzt immer noch
Klimaschutz also CO2 Emissionen
runter aber solche Emissionsminderungen
zeigen keine schnelle direkte Wirkung
das Klimasystem der Erde ähnelt einer
Badewanne mit verstopftem
Abfluss seit der Industrialisierung
lassen wir
Treibhausgasemissionen in die Badewanne
ein wenn wir den emissionshahn zudrehen
bleibt der stand erstmal
gleich denn einige Treibhausgase bleiben
hunderte manche sogar ende Jahre in der
Atmosphäre bis sie sich durch natürliche
Prozesse
[Musik]
abbauen wir haben nicht mehr viel Zeit
je länger wir den Klimaschutz
aufschieben desto gefährlicher wird das
Leben auf der Erde trotzdem tut sich von
Seiten der Politik zu wenig es wird nach
wie vor so getan als
wäre ja als wären Klimaschutzmaßnahmen
eine Zumutung für die Bevölkerung es
wird nie darüber geredet dass ich
tatsächlich ähm mit den Maßnahmen die
Lebensqualität der allermeisten Menschen
deutlich verbessern würde es wird
Politik für äh die Autoindustrie und für
die fossileindustrie gemacht es wird
nicht Politik für die Bewohner des
Landes gemacht ich glaube die
Gesellschaft ist an vielen Stellen sehr
viel weiter als die Politik zumindest in
den letzten Jahren gewesen ist das
Bewusstsein dafür dass wir etwas ändern
müssen äh dass wir die Wirtschaft und
unseren Lebensstil an bestimmten Ding
ändern müssen die ist aus meiner Sicht
da und jetzt gilt es das
zusammenzubringen mit den weichen
Stellungen in der
Politik der Klimawandel wird unser
allerleben stark
verändern so wie das von Meike und DTE
nkel für uns im Tal hier für alle
Menschen die hier leben und arbeiten es
ist einfach wichtig dass man außen sieht
dass diese
Flutkatastrophe er zwei Jahre vorbei ist
und nicht schon zwei Jahre die ganze
Zerstörung von Gebäuden Infrastruktur
von öffentlichen Gebäuden und
Privathäusern die ist einfach so immens
groß dass es einfach seine Zeit braucht
ich glaube die Frage warum das uns oder
warum das dem Aril passiert ist die die
stellt man sich nicht es ist passiert es
ist uns allen passiert ich denke wir für
uns haben haben uns entschieden den Weg
nach vorne zu richten und das Beste aus
dieser Situation zu
machen
extreme Wetterereignisse werden häufiger
die Folge sind unvorstellbare
Katastrophen die jeden treffen können
darauf müssen wir uns
[Musik]
vorbereiten
[Applaus]
[Musik]